Ukraine's president volodimir zielinski
is in Washington asking for more help in
the fight against Russia the visit comes
as Congress considers President Biden's
request for another 24 billion dollars
in Military and humanitarian aid for
Ukraine Mr President John and welcome
back to the White House in the Oval
Office
and earlier this week at the U.N General
Assembly I made it clear
that
that no Nation can be truly secure in
the world if in fact we don't stand up
defend the freedom of Ukraine from the
face of this Russian brutality and
aggression that's why we brought
together Coalition more than 50
countries more than 50 countries
to help Ukraine defend itself and it's
critical
that's why together with our Partners in
Ukraine we have provided humanitarian
Aid as well as tens of millions of
people with food clean water and so much
more and that's why that's why we've
begun the process of formalizing our
long-term commitment to Ukraine's
security alongside the G7 and with other
partners
and that's why we supported just the
lasting peace on the respection
Ukrainian sovereignty and its
territorial integrity
warm and strong Wars until the grants
from you the thing I think I appreciate
I'm glad to meet you it's already the
Showtime this year
thank you for invitation our regular
dialogue is prove that our Countryside
really truly allies and strategic
friends and we greatly appreciate that
vital assistance provided by the United
States to Ukraine to combat Russian
Terror really terrible today I'm in
Washington to strengths in our Collision
to defend Ukraine and children our
families our
freedom and democracy in the world and I
started my day in the U.S Congress to
thank his members and the people of
America for all the big huge sport I
felt trust between us and it allowed us
to have a Frank and constructive
dialogue Mr President and distrust and
support I felt from both Chambers and
those bodies and grateful
for this and now I look forward Mr
President to our discussion for the
benefit of our Nations and the world
when it comes to weapons we will discuss
everything with a special emphasis on
air defense and just to say that
especially this day
one year ago
we had we made
a big exchange of
prisoners
award presidents and journalists and
they had what this did we got home
Defenders of azusan and also citizens of
the United States and I'm happy that we
we did it Alexander rodruke and Andrew
Ty Hoon